hello everyone welcome to Paul and my
name is the Lang focused channel several
months ago I released a video on the
French language and more recently I
released a video on cockney rhyming
slang and that got me thinking about
french slang yes despite all the efforts
of the French Academy l'académie
française to promote proper French or
formal french french slang does exist
and is commonly used one interesting
type of French slang is called villain
that named villain comes from the word
long their meaning backwards or inverse
the word syllables are reversed and we
get that long the name of this type of
slang contains an example of the slang
Vermont is a kind of metathesis side by
side sounds switching positions and in
this type the basic idea is that two
syllables in a word switch places with
each other
note that this kind of slang originates
in the spoken language so the spelling
of the slang word comes from its sound
rather than vice-versa the S at the end
of long veil is silent that's why it's
not part of the word that long I think
you all know the standard French word
Mel C in Vietnam it's C mayor I'm sure
you also know the word Bonjour
can you guess what it would be in
Vietnam yes it's jus of bone then
there's the word see to you in Vietnam
it's two three
then there's the word Metro the metro or
subway in Vietnam it's ptomaine and the
word bazaar meaning weird or bizarre in
Vietnam it's zombie so where did this
slang come from and who uses it that law
began to arise in the decades following
World War two in the poor suburbs of
Paris
since then it has entered mainstream
culture through music TV movies and so
on it's still used most heavily by young
people in Livonia low-income suburbs of
France's major cities where mostly
immigrants and their descendants live
but a certain amount of Vietnam is used
by the wider mainstream population
especially young people this sentence
contains one of the most mainstream
violent words mo MEC Mott Lizabeth
Donohue this means my boyfriend looks at
other girls on the street the
long word here is must this is an
inversion of the word family so it
generally means woman or girl but in the
phrase mammoth it means my girlfriend as
opposed to ma femme
which means my wife I guess the
formality of the relationship is
reflected in the formality of the word
the word Mick is not very long but is
also slang which means something like
guy or dude and mum MEC means my
boyfriend in Paris though you might hear
people say kun which is a very long
version of MEK but that one is less
common than myth it might not be
immediately obvious how these single
syllable words become reversed at the
end of the word femme for instance there
is a release after the M consonant like
a schwa FEM that ma at the end becomes
the first syllable in the reversed word
and fact becomes the second syllable but
then the final vowel is dropped the
schwa sound from gets spelled as EU and
the vowel sound naturally changes a
little bit this is how most single
syllable verloc words are formed a few
more examples
Mayer meaning mother becomes boom jab
beat shimma whom this sentence means I
live at my mom's place pear meaning
father becomes look fat meaning party
becomes too unfailing to fellows on me
are we having a party at home in this
sentence contains one more very long
word soul may which is a reversal of
mais own the word meaning house
sometimes not just a vowel but a
consonant might disappear if it's
awkward to pronounce there's the word
fleek
which means cop like a police officer
and the Vermont word is cuff you might
be expecting it to sound like could flee
but the final syllable gets dropped and
it's just cooked at all Co
voila couth this means watch out the
cops are here
vlad by the way is an abbreviated form
of voila another common change that
happens is that a sound is removed
before the inversion takes place so we
have the word legal a meaning to laughs
which becomes goalie
so the ER ending was removed from the
word before reversing the two syllables
the innovators of slang normally stay
one step ahead of the general population
and when a word or expression becomes
two common they often stop using it in
the case of a law some words have become
Reaver on eyes door like double their
long before I mentioned the word fleek
which became verlan eyes to cook but
that word has become very well-known so
people verlan eyes dit again to [ __ ]
maybe it was Reaver lan eyes because the
police started to understand the word
cook and people wanted to talk about the
police without them understanding
another example the Vermont version of
the word a hub meaning Arab is BER and
this is one of the most well known
Vermont words
it became Reaver LAN eyes Daz Harbor and
move from family woman sometimes gets
Reaver LAN eyes to the moon use of that
law is not constant or consistent it's
usually limited to a couple of words in
each sentence and those same words are
not always used in their slang form also
when verbs are villainized
they can't be conjugated so verbs are
only used in these forms the infinitive
the present tense the imperative and
also the past participle so for example
for the word goalie from legal a -
laughs you can say jiggly meaning I
laugh
jiggly meaning I laughed with this
functioning as the past participle or
Java goalie I'm going to laugh with this
being the infinitive form you could also
use the imperative form goalie but the
meaning of that imperative form would be
kind of strange for this work for any of
the other conjugations you need to use
the standard verb legally and conjugate
it for example for the conditional
present form you would use illegal fa
sol ver claw is somewhat limited in when
it can be used now let's check out a few
examples of very long in context these
examples all come from the French film
called lion this movie takes place in
one of the lower income suburbs of Paris
where most of the population are of
immigrant background the film contains
numerous examples of very long here's
the first clip
[Applause]
they judged everything but I've actually
been invested with the guy in the clip
says Tim a lavash which means look at
the cow this word Tama
is the vet long word for Mata a verb
which we saw earlier in this sentence mo
MEK motley so to enough donahoo
now let's see that one more time a
little slower version here's one more
clip with the same word this time
someone says Tim a lavage
meaning watch the turn now let's see
that one more time here's another clip
with a different example in this clip
the guy says juice wila demo they lock
you of wa meaning I'm the demon of the
car and the scene they're about to steal
a car
the Vermont word is Q of WA which comes
from voix - meaning car
he actually pronounces the second
syllable in a more casual way saying
something like - of way instead of - of
wha
now let's see that one more time a
little slower
[Music]
and one more example so whaza looking
Trostle but the guy in the clip says
vlad kossei hulu which means go to sleep
annoying guy or something like that
the word of a lute comes from the word
lua which means heavy but hulu means
annoying or irritating now let's see
that one more time but she low very low
is a dynamic form of slang meaning that
it's always changing and old words might
go out of use and new words might arise
or words might become river line eyes
it's a kind of casual speech that you
won't find in textbooks and you might
find confusing when you first encounter
it you can learn some vellum online or
from books but you might sound funny if
you overdo it in the wrong context so
it's probably best to learn it in
context when speaking with native
speakers but for our purposes here today
it's simply an interesting linguistic
phenomenon to examined be sure to follow
Lange focus on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and once again thank you to
all of my amazing patreon supporters
especially these ones right here on the
screen these are my top two you're
patreon supporters and very many thanks
to them as always thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]